hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sail israels
heute gibt's ein kleines gepäck und zwar
vier strecken gemacht vier strecken mit
zartbitterschokolade und weißer
schokolade
das ist ein bisschen abgrundes wundert
muss sich jetzt ein bisschen abgewandelt
wirklich sehr lecker sein knusprig und
durch die kirchen natürlich auch
saisonal aktuell drückt mir gerade vor
sich
das hat nicht ganz da hingebracht naja
jedenfalls habe ich kirchen verwendet
und sind super leckeres gebäck was auch
sehr schnell vorbereitet ist denn ich
habe einen teig also eine streusel teig
den benutze ich für den boden und auch
für das topping und ich muss sagen ich
zeige euch mal die zutaten an zutaten
brauchen wir drei 100 gramm mehl 50
haferflocken 180 gramm zucker der prise
salz und etwas vanille extrakt 200 gramm
kalte butter und eine bio zitrone 2
eigelbe 100 g gehackte oder gestiftete
mandeln und 300 gramm entstand die
kirschen ich habe jetzt hier 400 gramm
liegen
ich werde zuerst einmal den sträußen
teig herstellen und dafür kommt jetzt
diese zutaten also haferflocken zucker
mehl und die butter
und das salz in der größe und das ganze
mache ich jetzt ohnehin maschine panel
extrakt kommt noch mit dazu und die
butter muss auch in kleine stücke
schneiden tag etwas irgendwas fehlt noch
die butter in stückchen also die mit
dazu und dann könnt ihr das nämlich
wirklich ohne küchenmaschine machen
ansonsten könnt ihr aber zum beispiel
auch einfache mixa benutzen und das
ganze in den mixer zu bereiten
das ist ein ganz praktischer teig weil
ich jetzt den die streusel hersteller
aber gleichzeitig auch den teig der als
unterlage dient und das machen wir jetzt
erstmal so jetzt könnt ihr zum beispiel
mit so einem gerät das ist jetzt was
extra für mit teig kann man damit den
teig zu hacken oder mit den händen kurz
zusammenführen
aber da solltet ihr darauf achten dass
der teig wirklich schnell geknetet wird
damit er nicht warm wird weil möglich
immer sehr kalt sein muss
nizam sich die streusel gut verbunden
jetzt kommen auch die zitronenschale mit
rein da solltet ihr auf jeden fall
darauf achten dass es eine unbehandelte
zitrone ist die sie zwei meter weil sie
grünes aber es ist eine zitrone in der
türkei schon immer ganz toll da sind die
zitronen oft auch erst grün und dann
werden sie gelb also wie gesagt zitrone
aber den limette wird natürlich auch
gern geschmack ich was ich damit sagen
wollte natürlich sind schon immer grün
vorher nicht so in der türkei aber
überall auf der welt aber dort werden
sie oft eben auch grün verkauft deswegen
kenne ich das von dort schon so dass
jetzt noch kurz unter berühren und jetzt
müsst ihr euch vorstellen dass ihr das
jetzt in vier teile teilt denn ich werde
jetzt ein viertel davon rausnehmen das
machen jetzt einfach kurz mit den händen
und zu den restlichen streuseln gebe ich
jetzt noch die 2 eigelbe mit dazu das
wird dann jetzt der teig der unten rein
kommt das jetzt kurz einrühren und dann
am besten ganz kurz mit den händen
verlinken oder wie gesagt auch einfach
mit der küchenmaschine oder mit dem
handrührgerät
die zeit habe ich jetzt kurz kühl
gestellt und kann ihnen da zwischenzeit
schon mal die kirchen in steinen können
natürlich ein kirchen steiger nehmen
aber falls ihr keinem habt nehmt ihr
einfach ein messer halbierte und nimmt
den kern heraus
jetzt kann ich den kuchen bereits in die
form geben und zwar bis jetzt begraben
den eckigen genommen und habe den auf 24
x 24 cm eingestellt wobei 24 5 ist die
eine seite weil man sie nicht kleiner
machen kann
das ist aber auf jeden fall super jetzt
nehme ich den teig und der kommt jetzt
als boden da rein
ihr könnt die form auch ein bisschen
größer machen wie ihr wollt ihr könnt
sie auf einem blech machen
allerdings hat man mit einem back rahmen
den vorteil dass ich eben an allen vier
seiten schöne ecken habe und da nix
wegschneiden muss ich werde später
dreiecke ausschneiden und ich mach das
jetzt 24 x 24 cm groß damit die damit
ich sie später quadratisch zu schneiden
kann auf acht mal acht und später dann
dreiecke habe sie dann richtig hübsch
aus seit mir den fingern graz ein
bisschen platt drücken mir das jetzt ein
bisschen größer habt werden die kirche
ecken später einfach ein bisschen
flacher und wenn ihr den kleiner macht
werden sie etwas höher
sag ich dir schön flach gedrückt jetzt
kommen die restlichen zutaten hier in
die große schüssel also die streusel die
man sich da habe ich jetzt noch ein paar
dabei die hatte ich mal in der pfanne
gerüstet die können jetzt auch mit rein
und die kirschen dann hier auch alles
ganz kurz mit den händen vermengen
jetzt kommt diese streusel machst du da
noch mit drauf und alles jetzt gut
verteilen sie seht es ein richtig
schneller kuchen also richtig schnelle
ecken bis jetzt also alles ganz fix
zusammengerührt und vor allem braucht
ihr kein spezielles equipment dafür
ein bisschen verteilen damit die kirchen
eben auch gleichmäßig auflegen und jetzt
kann's schon in den backofen und jetzt
kommst du den vorgeheizten backofen bei
170 grad ober unterhitze für ungefähr 45
minuten bis die streusel so ein bisschen
sport sind die kirchen sind es gebacken
und auch bereits abgekühlt jetzt kann
ich den tortenring entfernen
houghton retter und je einmal unter
diesem link
ich kann mir jetzt so drüber schieben
man muss nämlich nicht auf der back
folie schneiden denn die würde man
ansonsten zerstören jetzt schneide ich
dieses quadrat in 8 x 8 cm große
quadrate
also am besten im dir da ein ganz fertig
messen könnt einfach einmal durchdrücken
die quadrate werden jetzt noch in
dreiecke geschnitten was einmal diagonal
halbieren
jetzt kommt da noch einen
schokoladenüberzug drauf bzw jetzt die
ecken gleichen kurve habe ich hier
bereits 100 gramm kuvertüre im wasserbad
erwärmt das ist jetzt fast geschmolzen
und ich habe ich noch 50 gramm quartiere
das heißt ich mache wieder die impf
methode zwei drittel kuvertüre
geschmolzen ein drittel bleibt noch
draußen und sogar nicht die kuvertüre
temperieren damit sie eben keinen
grauschleier bekommt sobald die kultur
ist geschmolzen ist kommt noch die
restliche kuvertüre mit dazu aber ich
ziehe es vom wasserbad herr und jetzt
fröhlich so lange bis sie komplett
geschmolzen ist dann hat sie eine ideale
temperatur von etwa 29 30 grad
die karosserie ist jetzt soweit und
damit ich jetzt die ecken gleich ein
bisschen besser eintauchen kann
gebe ich die kuvertüre ein schmaleres
gefäß und zwar hier in so eine kleine
schale und ich habe hier übrigens im
restlichen heißen wasser einen beutel
mit etwas weißer kuvertüre und die da
verschossen
da darf aber die das war jetzt nicht
mehr zu heiß sein ist nämlich die
kuvertüre und tauche zwei ecken ein und
legt dann die fertigen ecken auch wenn
abkühlen gitter oder nehmen die
kuvertüre und lasst sie mit dem löffel
drüber laufen oder bestreicht die
teilchen mit einem pinsel
und wenn ihr dann mit der dunklen kommt
ihr fertig seid kommt die helle dran
wahrscheinlich ist eine ganz kleine ecke
ab und springt ihr das jetzt einfach
noch ein bisschen drüber
wurde ist der richtig lecker aus auch
richtig lecker
ich hab da herrscht doch schon ein paar
krümel der nacht könnte sein
ich hab mir grüße sinken sind ich meine
gerade noch keine dieser mir abholen ich
hab gedacht das ist etwas was uns gesagt
hast du probiert und das fossil actions
konsul jemals hatte keine chance
das sind kirche ecken 18 die hübsche
aber die erinnere mich auch total auf
dieses jahr wieder machen jedenfalls
lasse ich dir jetzt etwas abkühlen und
fest werden und dann darfst du probieren
und ich glaube die andere fraktion die
mache ich anders rum feller überzug und
dunkler schokolade okay die kirche ist
jetzt fertig und sind fest geworden und
habe hier übrigens noch ein paar ja so
ein bisschen resteverwertung gemacht
resteverwertung
ich habe einfach die übrige kuvertüre
genommen habe noch ein paar hafer kopf
mit rein gemacht oder mandeln es geht
auch und einfach so kleine kleckse
gemacht weil ich finde es immer ganz
schade
kuvertüre übrig hat und sich so wenig
uns noch aufzuheben
also kann man gut verwenden und zu
wegzuschmeißen
generic scheiße geht sowieso nicht
entweder muss man es auf nassen oder
eben noch mal was draus machen jetzt
hier darfst du mal probieren mir
übrigens während das dekor er uns noch
eingefallen wahrscheinlich noch mal so
einen extra-kick gewesen dann nochmal
eine schicht kirsch marmelade zwischen
dem boden und der streusel schicht zu
machen
also falls ihr wollten einfach eine
kirsche ladung noch rein und dann hat
man wahrscheinlich nochmal so ein
fruchtig mit dabei also das ist jetzt
ein bisschen trockene respekt ist es
genau und ich bin halt ein bistro gering
drucken gepäck passt für mich als jungen
es besser ja ja also wieder zu lernen
noch ein espresso haben ja dann kannst
du dir gleich nach draußen am see selber
naja ok alles auch wenn ich probiere ich
jetzt mal was die zuschauer nicht wissen
ist dass es heute schon das dritte
rezept ist das schon eine torte gegessen
habe und da habe ich noch stolz gegessen
bis ins dritte jetzt mal gespannt
ich hätte jetzt wieder hand
ja natürlich irgendwie beschwert
schauten ganz nah an
so sieht's aus waren sehr schön genau
noch so und jetzt daraus jetzt gleich
die ganze show koecke weg wahrscheinlich
nicht allzu trocken ja früher gab es
immer als hier also noch nicht ums essen
geachtet haben damals gekauft haben
meine eltern her da haben wir immer
diese schoko grenze gekauft so zur
kenntnis noch so mateschitz gebäck
genauso spitzen aber auch so schwarz mit
weil genau genommen so ungefähr schnecke
es nur noch ein bisschen genialer sport
grad sagt weiß gerade kurz bisschen
traurig weil sie sich auch selbst
gemacht und mit viel liebe wirklich
klasse
ja was jetzt auch einen ganz wichtigen
und bekommen habt und lust auf die
kirsche öko ecken bekommen habt dann
geht auf meinem blog auf der liste steht
es noch mal ganz genau für euch und wir
freuen wenn ihr dieses rezept nachmachen
wird foto sendet auf instagram oder auf
facebook da könnt ihr gerne auch immer
den hashtags alles wenn es machen und
wir schauen uns dann gerne die postings
soll also viel spaß zum nachbacken und
bis zum nächsten mal